as somebody who also has ADHD two things
one there's a book called ADHD 2.0 read
that book it'll give you some great
insights about how to manage ADHD in
this modern day and age but also
um help your son understand the
superpowers that he has because of his
ADHD I've talked about this before I
resent the fact that we tell children
they have a deficit and a disorder at
the end of the day everything is
balanced my ADHD gives me the power of
creativity it gives me the ability to
connect seemingly disconnected
information or if other people can see
those patterns I can do it a lot quicker
I can get more done in a day than most
people can done in a week when I'm
focused the problem is sometimes I'm
unfocused so help your kids see all the
advantages all the superpowers he has
over his friends and and amplify that
and yes it comes with some liability but
let's focus on those strengths